bill is with us in Connecticut hey Bill
how are you doing well thanks for taking
my call
sure what's up my son is a senior in
high school and he's looking at colleges
for next year and we have been fortunate
enough to save a nice 529 plan save
enough for pretty much any school that
he would choose there's roughly about
270 thousand in his 529 plan wonderful
we've been very fortunate to be able to
do that that said I want your opinion on
whether or not we should pay for his
entire four-year school or whether we
should insist that he paid for some of
it himself well I already know what your
view will be on debt but he could take a
job while in college and you know chip
away let's put a number on it perhaps
$5,000 in the course of the year right
and you think this is a good way of
having him put some skin in the game
would you say he needs to focus on his
studies whatever work that way well I
don't use it I don't use the studies as
an excuse because the data we we have
says that a kid who works 20 hours a
week actually has a higher GPA than one
that doesn't work so that's what the
data tells us now having said that I did
not and it sounds like you guys have
done very well financially and so you're
in a position to do most anything you
need to do here and he doesn't have to
pay for it the only question you're
looking for is him having skin in the
game him having focus and intensity and
intentionality about graduating and
studying hard and you know not get
sidetracked and you know take three
three classes and beer to beer pong or
something right
so exactly yeah and so what we did was
we just had real open discussions with
our kids we said you can work a job if
you want some extra money
here's your monthly budget for your
spending money we're gonna cover your
housing your tuition and your books and
you but your first job is to behave
and then we listed out what that meant
and for us it means that we're a family
of believers were family Christians and
so that means you're walking the way God
wants you to walk you're not you're not
rolling you know you're not doing a
whole bunch of weird crap and run around
doing stuff that most college students
do so you're going to behave morally the
second thing you're going to do under
the heading of behave is your job is to
go to class your job is to do the
homework your job is to make sure you
take the classes necessary and complete
them to graduate in four freaking years
not five that is your job if you behave
and you do the academic part of behave
and the moral part of behave we will pay
for this the moment that you don't we
will pay for zero and we just said this
is your job now in if you don't like the
budget that's okay you can work extra my
son worked a lot
he likes to he's entrepreneurial and he
liked to earn extra money and have some
extra pocket money and he worked a lot
while he was in school neither one of my
daughters did a lot Rachel did do some
events and things with us weekends and a
lot of stuff over the summers and things
Denise did a little bit too but neither
one of them held outside jobs outside of
Ramsey in terms of earnings so I didn't
do I didn't I didn't put that on him to
have skin in the game but we had very
very clear very blunt repeated over and
over and over for four years discussions
of what behaved looks like and that's
how you earn this money in other words
to go to school I'm not paying this
because you know you just happen to hit
the lotto and your last name is Ramsey
I'm paying this contingent upon you
behaving and it's taught does that make
sense of me and it worked for us all
three of ours graduated in three years
and you know none of them earned
drug-rehab and you know
so it worked and and I don't think they
are they all three work with us they're
the and they have excellent work ethic
they're not lesser they're not spoiled
brats you know which is kind of what
you're concerned about
and honestly I was concerned about that
too but we just said we're not going to
force you to do that and that's how we
handled it but you could do whatever so
it's just it's a neat discussion to have
and if you want to put five thousand
dollars on them not in debt but say you
have to earn five thousand dollars of
your deal every year just to prove you
can that's okay it's not that onerous I
mean this was it some five hundred bucks
a month or something geez
I mean that's not that big a deal you
can do that so what you're proposing is
not that out of line it's I just can't
tell you that I did it cuz I didn't I
did what I just outlined and and I got a
good result out of it but it was
combined with again a lot of very clear
aha open Ramsay style communication
there's a lot of stuff around Ramsay's
the within our family that happens but
lack of clarity arguments yes lots of
them lack of clarity no so heated
arguments yes lack of clarity nose so
that's how we approached it and it
worked out well for us and I'm okay I've
got a friend of mine that's a
multi-millionaire and he said I'm not
paying for a dime of their school they
can work their way through I did and he
put the whole thing on them guys that
wasn't what we did but that's it that's
what you want to do it's your kid and
your money and so you can go either
direction